اعلن الجيش الاسرائيلي نهايه العمليه
العسكريه في مخيم جنين وفيما اشادت قيادات
سياسيه وعسكريه اسرائيليه بما اعتبرته
نجاحا للعمليه اكدت فصائل فلسطينيه نشرت
مقاتلين في المخيم بعيدا انسحاب القوات
الاسرائيليه منه اكدت فشل تصعيد حكومه
نتنياهو العسكري في تحقيق اي من اهدافه
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم كندا خبر حلقتنا ولنا في نقاشه
ثلاثه مسارات كيف بدت حسابه الربح
والخساره لدى الاسرائيليين والفلسطينيين
في ضوء الاهداف التي رسمتها حكومه نتنياهو
للعمليه العسكريه الاسرائيليه بجنين ومن
انتهت اليه من نتائج ميدانيه وسياسيه
[موسيقى]
وضعت اذا العمليه العسكريه الاسرائيليه في
جنين او زارها مخلفه وراءها اسئله كثيره
بشان حسابات الربح والخساره لدى طرفي
المواجهه في ابعادها الميدانيه والسياسيه
الجيش الاسرائيلي وقال ان الجنود
الاسرائيليين انسحبوا من جنين بعد ان حققت
عمليتهم فيها اهدافها مضيفا ان تلك
العمليه العسكريه قادت الى تفكيك ست منشات
لتصنيع المتفجرات وثلاث غرف عمليات تابعه
للمقاومه الفلسطينيه كما قادت وفق الروايه
الاسرائيليه الى التحقيق مع ازيد من 300
فلسطيني واعتقالي العشرات منهم في المقابل
اكدت المقاومه الفلسطينيه انما يتحدث عنه
الجيش الاسرائيلي من تحقيق لانجازات في
عمليته بجنين لا يعدو ان يكون السوى
اوهامه واضافت الفصائل الفلسطينيه ان
مقاتليها افشلوا اهداف حكومه نتنياهو من
ورائي تصعيدها العسكري
ولوحت بخيارات مفتوحه في مواجهه اجندتها
وعلى وقع هذا التراشق الكلامي شن طيران
الحربي الاسرائيلي غاره على مواقع في غزه
ردا على اطلاق صواريخ من داخل القطاع
[موسيقى]
ليه مناقشه هذا الموضوع ينضم الينا من تل
ابيب دان شفان رئيس مركز دراسات الامن
القومي
واسرائيلي بجامعه حيفا في البدايه ثم ينضم
الينا ضيوفنا الاخرون
لنبدا بما تحقق بالنسبه لنتنياهو هو حل هل
تحقق له اي شيء غير الدمار الشامل والهائل
اعتقد لا يتعلق
فهناك توافق اراء كبير في ايران بان مستوى
الارهاب القادم من جنين يتطلب عمليه
عسكريه كبيره ولكن هذه مجرد بدايه ستكون
هناك عمليات عسكريه كبيره من هذا النوع
مره بعد اخرى واكثر من مره الى
لانه هذا يعني انه فقط نسيطر على الضرر
واذا هذه عمليه واحده وقريبه ستشهدون مع
عمليات اخرى وبالتالي هذا امر
كل اسرائيلي يتفق عليه ربما فقط اليسار
المتطرف بعض الافراد يعتقدون عكس ذلك ولكن
لا لا الامر لا يتعلق بل هذا احد الامور
القليله المقبوله من قبل كل اسرائيل نعم
ولكن الواقع يقول ان عمليه جنين وحدت كل
الفلسطينيين
صفا واحدا في مواجهه اسرائيل
وانها حولت ايضا جنين الى ايقونه للنضال
الفلسطيني والمقاومه الفلسطينيه
الفلسطينيون لديهم رموز مثل هذه منذ مئات
السنوات وهذا ما ادى الى النكبه وهذا ما
ادى الى معاناه هذا الشعب منذ 100 سنه
وعلى الارجح انه سيواصلنا
التضامنهم ويتواصلون استخدام النظام
المسلح
ولم يكن هناك حل مشكلتهم اذا ليس هناك حل
لهذه المشكله هل تحل بالعنف يعني هذا جيل
جديد من المقاومين الفلسطينيين سياتي
بعدهم جيل اخر من المقاومين الفلسطينيين
وهكذا
الفلسطينيون استخدموا العنف طالته دائما
منذ مئه سنه قبل حتى تاسيس دوله اسرائيل
وبعد تاسيس دوله اسرائيل قبل عام 67 وحتى
بعد ذلك وحتى بعد وقبل
اوسلاط جيده وعندك الاقتصاد جيده او سيئه
الفلسطينيين مدمنون على العنف وهذا هو
مصدر استراتيجيتهم ومن وجهه نظر اسرائيليه
السؤال الوحيد هو هل يمكن ان نواصل العيش
بشكل جديد رغم العنف الفلسطيني ولحد الان
منذ 100 عام الجواب هو نعم الحياه في
اسرائيل افضل وافضل يوما بعد اخر وكل عقد
وحياه الفلسطينيين ليست جيده وهم يعانون
واذا اردوا ان يضروا بذلك لعقد اخر او
لقرن اخر فليحصل ولكن تصويرك لاسرائيل
بانها حققت اهدافها وانتصرت اسرائيلي نفسه
اعترف بان الثمن كان باهضا في عمليه جنين
لو تحدثنا عن ميزان الربح والخساره ماذا
تحقق لنتنياهو ولحكومته اليمينيه ميدانيا
وسياسيا من هذه العمليه
ليس هناك اي اي فائده من التواصل لاي
اتفاق معهم مع الفلسطينيين لانهم ادمنوا
على الاعمال العنف ولكنك تنكر
اتساع يعني
الحاضنه الشعبيه الفلسطينيه للمقاومه
الفلسطينيه
جراء هذه العمليات المتتاليه
الاسرائيليين حول نظرته لما جرى لعمل
العمليه الاسرائيليه في جنين كيف ترد عليه
يعني لا شك بانه كل جمله ذكرها يمكن ان
نتحدث بها ساعات ولكن للاختصار ما ذكره
يمثل النظره التي تحولت الى نظره مركزيه
في المجتمع الاسرائيلي ليس فقط في
المؤسسات الدراسات او مؤسسات الامن
التي تتركز على مقوله ان انه يمكن الحفاظ
على الاحتلال يمكن بقاء الاحتلال يمكن
بقاء المستوطنات ويمكن توسيعها ويمكن ايضا
صناعه السلام بمعنى ان الفلسطينيين يجب ان
يقبلوا بنظريه سبوتريدج التي يتحدث فيها
عن حسم الصراع او حتى يتبنو النظره التي
وضعها بنيامين نتنياهو قبل اسابيع حين
تحدث عن انه يتوجب على الاسرائيليين
والعالم اقتلاع استعمل كلمه اقتلاع فكره
الدولتين حل الدولتين من رؤوس الفلسطينيين
بمعنى انه يعني وضع الاطار
النظري السياسي لفكره الحل المرجوه والتي
يعني تجاوزت تنظيرات السياسيه الى الواقع
بنيامين نتنياهو يعني وهذه الحكومه وايضا
قطاع واسع من المجتمع الاسرائيلي الان يضع
جذور
نظام الفصل العنصري من البحر الى النهر
بمعنى
توسيع الاستيطان والقيام بعمليه الضم
والتوسع في المناطق المحتله عام 67 مع
ابقاء نظام قانوني يعطي حقوق لليهود
ويمثل عمليه الاستعلاء القومي اليهودي
وابقاء الفلسطينيين على جانبي الخط الاخضر
دون حقوق قوميه وبحقوق وهذا ما تحدث عنه
دان شفتان بانه يعني اذا اردتم ان تحصلوا
على حقوق يعني مقابل ان تحصلوا على خدمات
صحيه وشوارع تنازلوا عن كرامتكم تنازلوا
عن قوميتكم تنازلوا عن حقوقكم الاساسيه
الشعب له حق في تقرير المصير وهذا يعني هو
جوهر وتلخيص ايضا لما يراه الاسرائيليون
انجازا فيما حصل في جنين يعني
التركيز على او محاوله التركيز وتضخيم
الانجازات الاسرائيليه
وكانها انجازات عظيمه يعني اسرائيل اذا
وضعنا قائمه تتحدث عن ماذا ما هي الاهداف
التي وضعتها اسرائيل مقابل ماذا تحقق من
هذه الاهداف نرى بانه يعني استعاده الهيبه
لم نرى بانه فعلا اسرائيل قامت باعمال
يمكن ان تكون استعاده هيبه استعاده
السيطره الامنيه راينا بان هناك عمليات
تفجير والغام اثناء الانسحاب راينا ايضا
عمليه في تل ابيب راينا صواريخ من غزه
وبكل ما يتعلق بمعاقبه الحاضنه الجماهيريه
في
التي احتضنت الحاضنه الشعبيه التي احتضرت
المقاومه من خلال التجريف قطع المياه
والكهرباء لا يمكن تسميتها انجازات واذا
كان الحديث عن يعني تدمير مصانع الغام
الحديث هنا عن مخيم لاجئين ليس عن معسكر
جيش عباره عن مخزون سكاني في منطقه مكتظه
يفتقر الى ابسط مقومات الحياه الكريمه
ولكن ويستخدم ادوات بسيطه يعني بالونات
غاز وغيرها من اجل صناعه هذه الاوقات لا
نتحدث عن صناعات تطوره
هذا بالنسبه للجانب الاسرائيلي مع عادل
شديد على الجانب الفلسطيني اذا وضعنا
الامور على ميزان الربح والخساره ماذا
تحقق وما لم يتحقق بالنسبه للفلسطينيين
تحياتي لكم للمشاهدين لا شك انه من خلال
حديثا
تكون الصوره واضحه انه هو يعترف ضمنيا من
حيث لا يدري ولا يشعر
بمسالتين متناقضتين الاولى ويقول انا
الفلسطينيين مارسوا العنف ضد اسرائيل منذ
100 عام قبل الدوله وبعد الدوله وسيستمرون
هذا اعترافا من من دانشيفتمان انه
الفلسطينيين لم يقبلوا الاحتلال ولن يقر
به ولن تستطيع الحركه الصهيونيه كسرهم
وايقاف العنف بمعنى انه في تطور بالخطاب
الخطاب الصهيوني التقليدي انه هم جاهزين
وقادرين على كسر وتيئيس الفلسطينيين
واحداث ما يسمى بكي الوعي وابن نتيجه
مفهوم وثقافه ونظريه الجدار الحديدي هو
يعترف الان انه انه كسر الفلسطينيين
ودفعهم لتوقف عن بين قوسين الكفاح المسلح
هي مساله مستحيله وهذا بحد ذاته
يضاف الى ميزان الخساره الاسرائيليه
والربح الفلسطيني المساله الاهم بتقدير
هي المرتبطه بالاهداف التي ذهبت بها
اسرائيل
للجنين لتحقيق هواء هل من الممكن بالقراءه
الموضوعيه ان نقول ان اسرائيل حققت
نسبه معينه منها طالما انه هنالك اجماع
اليوم في اسرائيل سياسي امن عسكري انه لا
يمكن
القضاء نهائيا على
ما يسمى بالعنف او الارهاب الذي يشكل
اليوم العلاقه الطبيعيه واعاد رسم العلاقه
بشكل هالطبيعي ما بين قوت الاحتلال والشعب
الفلسطيني المحتل اهم انجاز فلسطيني في في
الجوله الاخيره انه اسرائيل ارادت ان تعيد
فك فكه الحال الفلسطينيه السياسيه والوطني
والجغرافيه والاستفراد في جنين واعاده ما
يسمى قوه الردع عبر تحقيق الحد الاقصى من
الانجازات مقابل صفر
الغاضب جزئيا من السلطه الوطنيه
الفلسطينيه ومن ادائها
يعني لا شك انه انه
الحمل الاخيره العدوان الاخير على جنين
هذا الموضوع
والذي اعادوا هو الخطاب الصهيوني
الاستعماري الذي بنى السلوك على فرضيه انه
الاسرائيلي قادم بين قوسين للقضاء على هذا
الارهاب لتمكين السلطه الفلسطينيه مستقبلا
من العوده للحكم في في جنين وكان الازمه
هي فقط
في المقاومه وفي ضعف السلطه وليس في
الاحتلال الذي يشكل سبب كل هذه الازمات
سبب المقاومه سبب ضعف السلطه وما شابه
ولكن النتيجه اتت عكسيه تماما انه هذا
الالتحام
البطوله ما بين هاي المجموعات في كتائب
القسام مع كتائب الاقصى مع معصرايا القدس
مع كل الفلسطيني في ظل هذه الحاضن
الجماهري الواسعه اعاد اعطاء شرعية
للمقاومه المسلحه في ظل لاول مره تتبنى
القياده الفلسطينيه قياده السلطه قياده
منظمه التحرير جمله جديده
بحيث انه اعلنت انه او طالبت السلطه
واجهزه الامن بالدفاع عن الشعب الفلسطيني
وهذا خطاب جديد حتى وان لم يتم ممارسه
وتنفيذه ولكن
من الجانب الاسرائيلي لهذه النقطه مهمه
استاذ محمد زيدان العقل السياسي
الاسرائيلي الذي كان دائما حريصا على يعني
على عدم احراج السلطه عدم خساره السلطه
الفلسطينيه
وقال ذلك نتنياهو صراحه بانه لا يجب ان
تنهار السلطه لانهم بحاجه اليها هل حان
وقت خساره اسرائيل لهذه السلطه
يعني اعتقد بانه اسرائيل منذ البدايه يعني
اذا لاحظنا بالتصريحات الاولى مع انطلاق
عمليه الاجتياح تحدثت على ان الاجتياح
سيكون سيكون لمخيم جنين فقط وانه لا يهدف
الى المساس بمكانه السلطه اذا كان هذا
الحساب موضوعا في اهداف هذا هذا العدوان
الذي جرى على مخيم جنين وايضا في هذه
النقطه من المؤكد ان هذا الهدف لم يتحقق
بل العكس تماما اعتقد بانه ما نشاهد اليوم
على الارض في جنين يظهر بانه
العمليه اضعفت مكانه السلطه وخاصه غياب
الاجهزه الامنيه عن حمايه المواطنين الامر
الذي يعني وضع السلطه في موقف محرج مع
جمهورها يعني هذه حقيقه كانت خلال العدوان
كان هناك صراخ وكان هناك مطالبه بان تقوم
السلطه القيام بشيء ما من اجل الحمايه
وهذا السيناريو متكرر ايضا في اعتداءات
المستوطنين على الفلسطينيين في ترمسيه ومن
قبلها في حواره والان الجيش الجيش قام
بعمليه تدفيع ثمن يعني عمليه معاقبه اهالي
جنين ومخيم جنين تماما كما يقام كما يقوم
بذلك المستوطنين في البلدات الفلسطينيه
الاخرى ولذلك راينا بانه حتى بهذا الموضوع
عمليا اسرائيل بهذا العدوان ايضا اضعفت
مكانه السلطه وبالتالي الرهان على ابقاء
السلطه خارج الصراع هو امر يعني غير مضمون
على الاقل في المنظور الزمني القريب
كنتيجه طبيعيه لما حصل في جنين لكن هل
هناك بالفعل اجماع كما كان يقول قبل قليل
اجماع سياسي وامني وعسكري اسرائيلي ملتف
كله حول نتنياهو بما يضعف ربما المعارضه
التي كانت موجوده ضد نت نياهو لفائده
الاصطفاف وراؤه في عمليه جنين
يعني لا شك بانه نتنياهو كان هناك لديه
اهداف داخليه لم تعلن ولكنها كانت يعني
على الطاوله والجميع تحدث عنها نتنياهو
عمليا يشهد
انهيارًا من ناحيه قوته السياسيه مقارنه
بالاحزاب الاخرى هناك خلاف داخل المعسكر
اليمين الفاشي الاحزاب اليمينيه
الاستيطانيه تنافسه على الجمهور اليميني
الفاشل الشعبوي وايضا كان هناك تصاعد لقوه
احزاب المعارضه الاسرائيليه ولكن في موضوع
جنين راينا بانه المعارضه والائتلاف من
حزب العمل الى اقصى التيارات الفاشيه
الاستيطانيه كان هناك اجماع على تاييد
العمليه العسكريه في النتيجه النهائيه
يمكن ان يعني نرى
تماما كما في البنود المتعلقه بالاهداف
المعلنه نتنياهو اراد ان يظهر هو من يقرر
لم يدعوا مندوبي الصهيونيه الدينيه الى
اللقاءات التنسيق الامني خلال
العدوان
وكان يعني يريد ان يرسل رساله بانه هو من
يسيطر وهو من يقود العمل الامني ايضا في
الدوله ولكن على ارض الواقع التيارات
الفاشيه هي من فرضت هذا التصعيد وهي من
ضغطت وصعدت من اجل القيام به وبالتالي هي
شعرت بانها اكتسبت مكسبا اخر والان في
التحليلات العسكريه الاسرائيليه جميعها
تقريبا اليوم في الصحافه الاسرائيليه كل
المحللين العسكريين تحدثوا على ان ما كان
قبل العدوان على جنين سيستمر بعده بمعنى
ان هذه العمليه لم تؤدي الى تغيير جوهره
ولكن ايضا على المستوى الداخلي انها لم
تؤثر في معادله القوه ما بين المعارضه
والائتلاف ولاحظنا بانه حتى خلال العدوان
على جنين
الاحتجاجات يعني ايضا نتنياهو اراد ان
يهدئ
الاحتجاجات الداخليه التي كانت تخرج بسبب
التعديلات القضائيه خرجت هذه المظاهرات
خلال العدوان على جنين واستمرت وهذا الامر
يظهر بانه ايضا الاهداف الداخليه لم يستطع
نتنياهو ان
ينفذها وكان الاجنده الاسرائيليه السياسيه
الداخليه عادت ايضا الى ما كانت عليه قبل
العدوان على مخيم جديد ماذا بالنسبه لي
يعني على المستوى الاقليمي وربما الدولي
ما الادوار الذي يمكن يمكن ان تلعب في
هكذا اوضاع هناك من يتحدث عن دور للاردن
دور لمصر ربما في
المساعده في يعني ربما حللت الامور
مستقبلا كاين لا يتكرر ما يحدث او ربما
دول اخرى لا ندري
يعني اعتقد انه بالدوري الاقليمي يعني
اسرائيل معنيه بالحفاظ على الوضع الحالي
مع الدول العربيه تحديدا مصر والاردن ولكن
قدره مصر والاردن على الضغط على اسرائيل
اعتقد انه التجارب الماضي يعني كشفت انها
محدوده جدا اسرائيل يعنيها مسالتين اهم
المحددات الاسرائيليه هي الموقف الامريكي
الذي تجلى بشكل واضح ان الولايات المتحده
رغم الازمه الحاليه ما بينها وبين الحكومه
الاسرائيليه
كانت داعمه بشكل واضح
للسلوك العدواني الاسرائيلي وهذا تحدثه
يعتبر نقطه مهمه جدا كرساله للقياده
الفلسطينيه للسلطه للدول العربيه التي
تراهن على دور امريكي مع اي ازمه تناشد
الاداره الامريكيه تدخل لما يسمى بالضغط
على الاسرائيلي يتبين ان الولايات المتحده
اعطت الضوء الاخضر ودعمتها العدوان الاس
هذا الجانب الجانب الاخر يعني اسرائيل
الكل في الميدانيه بكل الاحوال
استخدام هذا الكم من الطائرات
[موسيقى]
اعتبر ادركنا
الوقت وانتهى وقت البرنامج اعتذر لمقاطعتك
شكرا جزيلا لك الاستاذ عادل شديد الكاتب
والمحلل السياسي كنت معنا من الناصره
ونشكر ايضا ضيفنا من الخليل محمد زيدان
الصحفي المختص بشؤون الاسرائيليه شكرا
جزيلا لكما
وبهذا ناتي الى ختام هذه الحلقه من برنامج
ما وراء الخبر لكم منا اطيب المنى والى
اللقاء
[موسيقى]